at 40 years old Patriots quarterback Tom
Brady shows no signs of slowing down in
a game dominated by younger players he
says this dude is unique fitness and
diet regime it's described in his new
book the t b12 method how to achieve a
lifetime of cysteine sustained peak
performance it's published by Simon &
Schuster a division of CBS and Brady
gave us an inside look at his fitness
routine and the keys to success you know
some people want denser muscles as an
athlete as a quarterback I don't want
them I want to keep my muscles strong
and active but also pliable you describe
my ability as lengthening and softening
of the muscles yeah but everybody thinks
they want muscles to be harder I think
that's what we've been educated on well
I may argue something differently I've
seen really strong physically fit guys
that you know would be the definition of
health that are ones that are injured
the most and if I can keep my muscles
pliable I can hopefully you know limit
the intensity or limit the injury
altogether you know if I do absorb some
of these forces on average a
professional football player lasts just
six years in the NFL
compare that to Brady who is two games
into his 18th season he credits his
longevity to a more holistic approach to
fitness we talked about rehab all the
time right we get injured and we go to
rehab yeah you talk about pliability in
terms of prehab yeah
meaning pliability can prevent injury
yeah not just athletes but for everybody
you know everyone does my parents could
do it my sisters can do it I mean I did
pliability this morning on my son whose
leg was sore I mean he's eight years old
you're sort of trying to make the case
that pliability is a whole different way
to kind of look at athleticism it's a
philosophy he adopted after meeting
longtime trainer and business partner
Alex Guerrero you describe Alex Guerrero
is not a body coach but a body engineer
yeah when my elbow was in pain
basically every day and Alex through his
treatments this was in 2004 he started
lengthening and softening all that all
the muscle in my form and it took away
the tension in the muscle and I was like
God that makes so much sense the band
here pliability can be achieved in part
by a lot of band
work bien work what will I would say
increase your strength while limiting
the density of the muscle the dense of
the muscle means the less pliable it is
most of our workouts are all resistance
bands based Brady's Sports Therapy
Center doesn't look like an average gym
90 percent of the training is done with
these flexible bands followed by very
specific massage techniques to focus on
problem areas of the body I would say
I'm faster now and quicker now then you
know when I first started playing
football you know even in high school
you're faster at age 40 than at age like
18 yeah I am all my friends who are moms
are gonna be saying to their husbands
like Tom Brady's better at 40 then we
was at 18 then there's all these bands
in their Christmas you really want to
play into your mid 40s yeah that's the
goal for me and does Gisele agree with
that I think we go back and forth I mean
she always say to me well ten years ago
you told me it was only gonna be ten
years and now it's ten years and now
you're saying another you know five
years
you worry about concussions I don't
worry about him no I mean I'm not
oblivious to him some of my idols had to
retire because of head injuries
yeah I'm conscious of it but I also love
the sports so much that I want to keep
playing and I'm gonna do everything I
can to take care of my body in advance
of the you know the hits that I'm gonna
take on Sunday that's a great piece
what's interesting about him is that he
has made himself this way he was not
always expected to be the best athlete
on the field he was six round draft pick
and he has worked so hard and it shows
on on the field what every level much
more tomorrow I want to get myself some
bands
you